ich grüße herzlich ursula nonnemacher
brandenburgische ministerin für soziales
gesundheit integration und
verbraucherschutz von ohlemacher noch
regieren sie nicht aber eines haben die
parlamentarier der potenziellen
ampelkoalition trotzdem gestern schon
entschieden die bis zum 25
november beschränkte epidemische lage
von nationaler tragweite soll auslaufen
ist das ein kluges signal in der
aktuellen situation wie wir sie gerade
auch im beitrag gesehen haben
die verlängerung der epidemischen lage
war ja schon das letzte mal heiß
umkämpft und reis umstritten wegen der
starken eingriffe in grundrechte der
sehr stark grundrechts intensiven dinge
die in § 28a des
infektionsschutzgesetzes geregelt sind
wie zum beispiel ausgangssperren kontakt
beschränkungen da haben wir sicher jetzt
eine andere situation
durch die hohe grad an impfungen die
inzwischen in deutschland
erfreulicherweise erreicht worden sind
aber es ist selbstverständlich kein
anlass jetzt hier von freedom day oder
wir haben alles überstanden zu reden und
deshalb bin ich auch sehr froh dass die
ampel koalitionäre gestern ein papier
vorgelegt haben in dem doch ganz klar
gesagt wird wir schaffen im
infektionsschutzgesetz jetzt wieder eine
gesetzliche grundlage
das masken pflicht abstandsregeln 2g 3g
regeln dass diese dinge auch weiterhin
verlängert werden können sie haben den
freedom day gerade angesprochen also
dieses gefühl jetzt ist die pandemie
vorbei wie wollen sie denn sicherstellen
dass das nicht das signal ist dass von
dieser politischen maßnahme ausgehen
könnte in die gesellschaft
wissenschaftler gehen davon aus dass die
fallzahlen in diesem herbst und winter
sogar höher sein könnten als im gleichen
zeitraum im letzten jahr bin befürchten
sie nicht dass mit dieser aufhebung der
nationalen
epidemischen lage von nationaler
tragweite ein falsches signal ausgeht an
die menschen
ich habe ganz klar gesagt wir müssen und
das hat auch die
gesundheitsministerkonferenz immer
wieder fokussiert sagen wir sind mitten
in der vierten welle wir haben gerade in
den letzten tagen sehr starke anstiege
desinfektions geschehens in der
bundesrepublik aber jetzt auch bei uns
in brandenburg wir waren ja bisher immer
noch am unteren level desinfektions
geschehens auch bei uns nimmt das jetzt
wirklich sehr zu wir haben jetzt den
herbst und winter vor uns und es ist
keine zeit für entspannung
es ist bloß halt die frage auf welche
eingriffe man sich jetzt beschränkt und
ich sage unsere umgangs verordnung zum
beispiel in brandenburg beruht auch auf
diesen sachen abstandsregeln masken
pflicht im pnv beispielsweise
zugangsbeschränkungen hygiene konzepte
und diese dinge müssen natürlich
weiterhin mit großer intensität beworben
und auch verfolgt werden und da schafft
jetzt offensichtlich der bundestag die
gesetzliche grundlage das ist nötig und
das ist zu begrüßen das möchten wir im
übrigen wollte ich natürlich noch sagen
weil ich natürlich noch sagen es bleibt
auch wenn die leute es nicht mehr hören
können natürlich dabei wir haben jetzt
die pandemie der ungeimpften dieser
ausspruch ist und bleibt richtig und ich
kann immer wieder nur dazu motivieren
impfen impfen impfen wir haben immer
noch gerade auch hier bei uns in
ostdeutschland eine impfquote die viel
luft nach oben hat in allen
altersgruppen und natürlich müssen wir
auch die auffrischimpfung jetzt gerade
bei wohlen rahmen und hochaltrigen
weiterhin mit nachdruck in angriff
nehmen also das thema impfen auch wenn
die neuerliche forsa-umfrage jetzt
gezeigt hat dass viele leute halt dem
auch kritisch gegenüberstehen das thema
impfen ist weiterhin ein schlüssel zur
bekämpfung der pandemie wenn sie die
noch niedrige impfquote auch vor allen
dingen in ostdeutschland ansprechen bei
ihnen in brandenburg ist die anzahl der
vollständig geimpften im verhältnis zum
bevölkerungsanteil auf dem vorletzten
platz bundesweit sehr liegt bei 60,2
prozent
woran liegt das diese im chat ist es
also ich denke das hat sicher sehr viele
gründe da gibt es nicht einen grund
dafür aber wir haben natürlich in den
letzten wochen und monaten in
zusammenarbeit mit den kommunen wirklich
alles versucht auch durch
niedrigschwellige angebote skeptische
menschen zu erreichen und mit in bussen
und
aktionen vor einkaufszentren und so die
entsprechend kritische bevölkerung noch
zu motivieren aber wir haben natürlich
hier auch eine verfestigte anzahl an
impfgegnern an sehr kritischen gegnern
und zum teil korreliert das natürlich
auch ganz klar mit der anhängerschaft
von rechtspopulistischen parteien die
entsprechende kampagnen fahren oder auch
stimmung machen gegen impfkampagnen oder
gegen das tragen von masken oder gegen
aufklärungsarbeit an schulen und da
haben wir natürlich große probleme und
dass die impfquoten in ostdeutschland
niedriger sind hat halt auch mit diesem
phänomen zu tun frau nonnemacher wenn
die epidemische lage von nationaler
tragweite auslaufen würde
fünfundzwanzigster november damit geht
im bund ja auch ein wichtiges
steuerungselement verloren also ein
stück zentralisierung der korona
maßnahmen die maßnahmen werden dann
wieder in die hände der länder gegeben
dh es kommt wieder eine art
flickenteppich an corona maßnahmen auf
uns zu
in der ich sagte ja gerade dass ich das
gestern vorgestellte eckpunktepapier der
ampel verhandlungs man sozusagen so
verstanden habe das ja gerade eine
bundesgesetzliche regelung für die
maßnahmen die wir weiterhin brauchen
geschaffen werden soll also den
flickenteppich sehe ich nicht sondern es
wird ja
zentral durch den neuen deutschen
bundestag dieses gesetzlich geregelt
werden und damit haben wir einen
einheitlichen rahmen und ich denke die
ministerpräsidentenkonferenz die letzte
woche in nordrhein-westfalen getagt hat
hat ja auch entsprechende beschlüsse zur
epidemischen lage gefasst das geht in
dieselbe richtung also ich sehe da jetzt
nicht den flickenteppich sondern ich
sehe dass die instrumente die im moment
von den ländern eingesetzt werden
zugangsbeschränkungen kontakt
nachverfolgung dass das weiterhin
möglich ist durch bundesgesetzliche
regelung das ist dringend erforderlich
aber von daher sehe ich nicht dass wir
da im regen stehen und keine instrumente
mehr ich sagt herzlichen dank für das
gespräch oder laune macher
bitteschön als armin laschet ist also
laschet war ja der große integrator der
für einen sehr mutigen kursstand und der
auch eine sehr ausgleichende art hatte
hendrik wüst war in der vergangenheit
klarer dem konservativen flügel
zuzuordnen also mit einer klaren
marktliberalen auffassung er hat damals
als generalsekretär unter jürgen
rüttgers bis 2010 durchaus harte
kampagnen gefahren gegen die damalige
oppositionsführerin hannelore kraft
allerdings so sind zwei alte geschichten
nur begrenzt aussagefähig also jetzt
steht natürlich einen rollenwechsel an
hendrik wüst hatte als verkehrsminister
schon anders agiert und jetzt wir haben
das ja auch gerade in seiner rede
gesehen streckte die hand aus auch in
richtung opposition und lobt im grunde
die modellierten modernität und vielfalt
des landes also ich glaube wir dürfen
gespannt sein wie er sich in diesem amt
jetzt neu präsentiert die personalfrage
hat die cdu in nordrhein-westfalen
geklärt die neuaufstellung der
bundes-cdu die steht allerdings noch aus
die kreisvorsitzenden treffen sich am
wochenende vielleicht beginnt das neue
erkenntnisse angesichts dieser vielen
unterschiedlichen stimmen und strömungen
die wir derzeit aus der cdu hören in
welche richtung wird es denn gehen was
glauben sie
das ist so ein bisschen die
gretchenfrage das ist natürlich völlig
offen weil die kurs frage entscheidend
daran hängt wer tatsächlich neuer cdu
vorsitzender wird da sind ja die
bekannten namen im spiel das ist so ein
bisschen wie täglich grüßt das
murmeltier also es wird wieder jens
spahn genannt es wird wieder friedrich
merz genannt und es wird wieder norbert
röttgen genannt auch als brinkhaus soll
ambitionen haben und eine jens spahn cdu
sehe natürlich ganz anders aus als eine
friedrich merz cdu und wer sich am ende
durchsetzt ist wirklich stand jetzt
offen allerdings glaube ich dass die
union die ja jetzt nach 16 jahren
plötzlich wieder opposition machen muss
eine konstruktive oppositionsarbeit
machen muss also wir werden einen kurs
erleben der in der mitte bleibt der
versucht eigene ideen zu präsentieren
der versuchte auch die ampel an
bestimmten stellen anzugreifen aber ich
habe nicht die befürchtungen diese these
gibt es ja auch von manchen dass die
dass die cdu jetzt abdriftet in richtung
rechts und neben der afd in der
opposition sich plötzlich radikalisiert
also ich glaube wir werden weiter eine
moderne konservative kraft der mitte in
deutschland haben schauen wir noch mal
auf ein anderes thema die
bundesregierung hat gestern ihre
wachstumsprognose gesenkt also es läuft
nicht mehr so gut wie noch vor einem
halben jahr was bedeutet das jetzt für
die koalitionsgespräche von spd grüne
und fdp
das sind schlechte nachrichten für olaf
scholz annalena baerbock und christian
lindner weil die koalitionsgespräche im
moment an einem punkt kranken das sind
die finanzen also man ist sich glaube
ich bei vielen themen schon in groben
umrissen einig aber die frage wie alles
finanziert werden soll ist offen und
wachstum bedeutet ja immer geld für den
staat also steuereinnahmen und wenn das
jetzt nach unten korrigiert wird aus
völlig nachvollziehbaren gründen also
wir haben steigende energiekosten es
gibt probleme mit den lieferketten also
die industrie leidet unter diesen
entwicklungen das bedeutet auch weniger
einnahmen für den staat und dieser
effekt ist für die amt